there are moments when everything aligns
and this was bmx's day
kai white who they call the prince of
peckham led the charge
watching him waiting for her final beth
shriver was shaking
trying to control her joy for kai and to
focus on herself
that's what she does whatever it takes
to chase the dream
as beth crossed the line kai white was
going berserk
he scooped her up the girl from essex
and the prince of peckham
children for their home games in 2012.
now olympic heroes it's an amazing sport
it's so thrilling the adrenaline
yeah it gets everyone going so i'm so
glad people have got the opportunity to
watch it and to actually
celebrate something as well in the
country she was winning that race
and she was leading it like she was
meant to be the champion
and the champion was right behind her so
it yeah it just speaks volumes because
when she came across that line she said
she was shouting but i was shy so much i
couldn't hear her
after women's bmx had its funding cut in
2016 beth was forced to raise money by
crowdfunding
and she worked as a teaching assistant
just to get to competitions
gb cycling did eventually take her on
full time
what could proper funding do to bmx for
girls oh
i think it would open up so many doors
for us i think
we need more girls in the sport i'm the
only only woman at the moment so i have
to deal with training with the boys 24
7. so yeah to get a few more girls
involved and to get them through the
process would be amazing
peckham south london it all went off
the way the uk has supported us today
has been absolutely obscene
like kids staying up till 5 a.m just to
watch me
and um yes yes it was flipping crazy
and the love and support has been crazy
their finals here were over in less than
a minute
but what they've done for their sport
will last for years
it's the ups and downs of bmx that make
it so exciting and you can almost
guarantee now
that there are more children wanting to
have a go and wanting to do whatever it
takes
to get to the olympic games tokyo 2020
could easily have been cancelled but for
all the challenges
it has produced these kinds of moments
the moments
that explain why they do it tom
parmenter
sky news tokyo